well santa claus that man there  partnered with fort apache commons and  the serving our kids foundation today  to host a drive-through food drive their  goal to make over 3 500 weekend meal  bags for  70 clark county schools they say it's  more important now than ever to make  sure families have the help they need  right now food insecurity in the valley  is at a probably an all-time high  it's unbelievable how many families need  help in this valley and  we're just here to do our part to make  sure that the kids have food to eat and  give extra food to the families for over  the holiday weekend  vegas golden knights player derek  england and his family were also there  to lend a hand  his son collected over 270 dollars and a  lot of apples for the drive so great  the first 50 cars at today's event were  given cowabunga bay tickets  for next season